hey guys how's it going so today this
video I actually shot this weekend but I
kind of needed just a little break from
editing and my computer so I never ended
up even editing or posting this video so
this was before I got my iPhone and
everyone I just wanted to officially let
you know I have it it's in my possession
so if you want to see the unboxing of
the official iPhone 7s 9 7 s 7 plus the
7 plus I'll put a link in the
description you guys can go check that
out if you haven't seen it already oh
yeah this is uh this is a vlog hope you
enjoy it I don't even remember what
happened because there's a few days ago
but sometimes you guys say I'd rather
see the vlog then you're not posted at
all so here you go hey everyone how's it
going I hope you guys are doing very
incredible I'm extremely tired this
morning for whatever reason I've got to
go to the eye doctor good boy yes you
must have known that I had to leave one
of his very very skilled commands is go
to your cage go to your cage good boy
yes I have some furniture that I need to
get so I may go look at that today but
the biggest news is Jenna's moving into
her new apartment today so I'm excited
gonna go do the eye exams good I'm gonna
see if I can maybe go and pick up an
iPhone I'm gonna check a couple stores
and see if anybody has one if not it
looks like mine is supposed to be here
on Monday but it's in Hong Kong right
now it's Saturday it's almost Sunday in
Hong Kong I'm not sure if it's really
gonna be here or not I do have the new
ceramic watch which is incredible you
guys haven't seen at unboxing this one
actually did unbox let's go get our eyes
trapped
you
I just drove past I saw a t-mobile and
I'm going to go in there and see if
you've any plus films hopefully I'm not
late for my appointment because my
appointment is in like four minutes so
hopefully they have one and if I am late
I'm gonna go in the store maybe get a
couple upgraded kitchen items look at
all these mixing bowls something that I
never thought I'd be into here we are
this is adulthood going having a nice
Saturday morning stroll to the cooking
store to t-mobile and to the eye exam
not
no7 plus just just so crazy like none
so really successful eye exam my contact
my prescription I'll stay the same it's
the same for the past nine years she
said at least I think that's the nine
years that we're going to this current
place so now I'm going to head to the
Apple Store and I'm going to see if they
have any phones I'm hoping that they do
I also know how my phone key to make it
home home to my house on Monday that's
really far shrimp
Matt how many times I walk on this Third
Street Promenade I just can't get over
the fact that this looks exactly like
real-life grand theft auto they don't
think there was any farmers market in
GTA III GTA again oh crap I love that
game is this a meat vending machine a
vending machine from meat they're
dispensing meat
and I said they're giving away three
Lego what
[Music]
yeah Mohammed ago I want to check it out
but I also would like a phone let's say
we can see the look to be too busy
oh my goodness okay so I didn't see this
line here I just walked in
I'll go see if they give me the free
Lego puzzles ooo added again
um can you look at this it's a it's a my
pad touch it's busier than I've had four
children and I did you tiny phone
somebody have a baby I can buy those for
their child go I felt really bad because
there's like a lot of little kids there
and I feel like they deserve the Lego
more than me my parking is going to be
up in 20 minutes there's no phone I
guess I'm gonna go home and see my dog
give him some snuggles please I got new
contact so I can see I'm gonna go see
Jenna her new place my camera lens is
really dirty
no phone but I did accidentally a stop
at the shoe store and got myself a new
pair of Nike jad just texted me she's
all moved in and I ordered her a present
so it should be at my place very soon
and I can take it to her she thinks as a
puppy but it's actually a Hugh starter
kit for lights you light kit I think
she's actually gonna be more into that
than a puppy less maintenance I also
noticed ibex breakfast sandwich and
shout out to the guy that worked there
he watches YouTube videos so if you are
seeing us now hello I'm gonna enjoy the
sandwich always little tails movin Jenna
I saw your present I haven't given you
today's in a really wild day I'll tell
you about in a minute I don't feel like
discussing now but we're gonna go get
ice cream look at this new pad Jen show
me around give me attention this looks
real nice you a great job look at this
okay that light is great I wish it was a
little bigger so this is not my dress in
my dresser will be later on next week
here's the light though that's cute
funeral home okay well says the person
who doesn't clean an apartment like a
funeral that would look very nice
so I'm fine everything survived so I am
hired to do it it's okay it's a nice big
closet
nice big bathroom
there's my mad where do I get to sleep
over kind of sleep over oh yeah yeah you
can choose this is where you're destined
to be yes my desk over here this is my
chairman very nice it's here but it
needs assemble it has does a chair I
like it I'm real on to it hi sweet
little kitty we had a time today didn't
we
you're looking very very cute and so
much better you're very sweet kitty OS
okay baby Mason keep it be well thank
you guys for watching this vlog of
whatever it was that I did this weekend
as an update as Kat is doing so much
better
his kitties are like the sweetest cats
in the entire world you guys should go
follow them on Instagram and Twitter
because they're just they're beautiful
it's not that I'm not a cat person
I am super allergic to cats so even to
be able to hang out with Ed's cats I had
to take claritin and it helped for a
while but I think I only took the
12-hour Claridon so by our Dober 12
before I went to sleep I was in struggle
City the man is worth it because they
are like the sweetest cats ever I can't
even express to you how amazing these
cats are so freakin cute I just wish I
wasn't allergic because I would snuggle
them so much
alright I'm gonna go I'll see you guys
in the next video happy whatever day
today is see you later
so sue me he just pops right in there oh
so here's what you do so you just take
off this back screw and then you screw
it to this I feel like that could've
been easier maybe it's childproof do we
have like a first step what's our first
step
open